so politico puts this out
on their website quote joe biden chose
kamala harris to become his running mate
for the 2020 election on august 1st
two weeks before the democratic national
convention after keeping his choice
close to the chest for months
in his announcement biden called harris
a worthy opponent and a worthy running
mate
alluding to the pair's rivalry during
the earlier stages of the democratic
primary
she will bring her experience as a
prosecutor household name recognition
and skill
as a debater to the ticket
so politico walks this back because as
you might notice it's not august 1st yet
so how do what what is this announcement
joe biden hasn't announced anything to
my knowledge
they said oh that's just placeholder
text
you know i've i've worked around
newspapers and websites and politics
very bit
that ain't placeholder text that's not
placeholder text actually is this kind
of nonsense latin
which is called it's called lorem ipsum
and it's just the kind of nonsense latin
that you
fill in sometimes so you can figure out
how things gonna be spaced out on a page
you don't get very very specific about
who
joe biden chooses for his running mate
and how he chose her
and when he did it and what the quotes
were
seems to me the campaign is leaning
heavily in her direction
though with all of the leaks about
kamala harris
they're clearly taking the temperature
and maybe some people are working
against her on the campaign
in any case joe biden is getting pretty
serious
they will because of the extended
lockdowns be able to craft whatever
image they want
you don't need to worry so much about
the gaffes on the campaign trail
this will only favor the left because
the big tech masters of the universe
only favor the left whenever there's a
little accident a little glitch a little
bug
and you know some search results i don't
know there's search engine manipulation
and
all the left-wing sites seem to pop up
but not the right-wing sites or there
will be some terrible defamation of a
conservative on the internet but then
they'll get rid of it
all those accidents all those glitches
only seem to go
in one direction i hope you enjoyed that
short segment from the michael knowles
show be sure to check out the full
episode linked in the description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
you